everything i know about cooking i've
learned through hard work drive and
passion from the age of 17 i made food
my life and it's fair to say that since
then food has been the making of me but
the sort of cooking i made my name with
intricate dishes made with the world's
finest ingredients is a million miles
away from the food i grew up on
for the first program in the series i'm
updating some of the home-cooked dishes
i absolutely adored when i was a kid
first up for breakfast at classic from
my childhood stunning baked beans with
fluffy potato cakes next a modern take
in my favorite childhood lunch fantastic
fish fingers and an irresistible chip
butty my mouth is salivating
and i've got competition in the kitchen
as mum helps make dinner
dad shouldn't manny be doing the cousin
because she's the better cook excuse me
when i was a kid this is my dream dinner
super comforting shepherd's pie with
peas and carrots followed by a steamed
date pudding with butterscotch sauce to
die for
let's get this show on the road
this is my ultimate childhood food
breakfast lunch and dinner
first a breakfast to really set you up
for the day easy homemade spicy fake
beans with deliciously light potato
cakes
[Music]
the first big thing
that i remember as a kid was
bacon
and beans
so this is like a little rendition
except we're using the most amazing
pancetta ernie come on
disappear
go and chase some mice now panel get
nice and hot i'm gonna turn these beans
into
glamorous beans pancetta into the pan
lightly
season that it's cured so it doesn't
need that much seasoning
now start frying off that pancetta
it's amazing how the individual tastes
of baked beans they're somewhat bland so
i always like to make them a little bit
more spicy
so
a nice finely chopped chili
with
the seeds
chili in
now a little bit of garlic
crushed
phenomenal
[Music]
get that bacon really nice and crispy
fry off the chili
and the garlic
and then onions my top tip for dicing
finely sliced downwards
slice across
then cut down to simply dice
bacon onion chilli garlic
that flavor all contained in that little
pan
once you've sweated the onion off
a little bit of sugar in there
the brown sugar will start to caramelize
darken
and enrich it as well at the same time
that looks beautiful
now
a couple of tablespoons of cider vinegar
delays the pan it's got that really nice
powerful kick to it now spice that up
with one of my favorite seasonings
worcester sauce
bring that to the boil
and add your
passata puree tomatoes
turn that down
simmer the sauce to reduce
then add in the classic baked bean
harrico beans
you can buy haircut beans dried or
canned they are packed with protein and
have a lovely soft texture
turn down the heat
and let the beans absorb
all that beautiful spicy tomato sauce
and just let that simmer now
five or six minutes now for my potato
cakes they're a fantastic way to use
leftover boiled potatoes and are so easy
to make
i'm making a simple potato dough by
adding flour and butter to the mash
that gives it that nice sort of
cakey texture and it goes from this
leftover ball potato
to this nice light
flowery
potato heaven take a nice
spoon of potato lightly flour your board
we're gonna fry these
crisp
on the outside and just
nice and fluffy in the center
now
get your pan nice and hot
we'll start off with olive oil
into the pan
now put the butter around the outside
because it starts heating up by the time
it goes into the center
it's almost sort of nut brown
gently
turn them over
love that nice
light crisp
they look beautiful
now take them out
potato cake in the middle
and a nice
beautiful
spoon
of beans
growing up with beans on toast as a
treat
still to this day after all those years
has not changed my love or attitude for
beans
especially cooked like that
[Music]
smoky spicy homemade baked beans with
light and creamy potato cakes comfort
and satisfaction on a plate
[Music]
coming up i'll be showing you more the
food that made me the man i am
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
shop for to make my ultimate lunch and
dinner
starting with pollock
i grew up on whitefish like cod and
haddock but today i'm using pollock
whitefish like pollock has a wonderful
sweet firm flaky flesh
pollock's so versatile
bake it batter it cook it up in fish pie
or even cut it into strips for my fish
fingers which i'm cooking for lunch
growing up i ate tons of lamb minced
meat it's generally from less expensive
but tasty cuts like neck and belly
you can use lamb mince in so many ways
in middle eastern copters or mixed with
mint for a twist on a traditional burger
but as a kid i couldn't get enough of
shepherd's pie and i'm making an amazing
version for dinner
i ate potatoes almost every day as a kid
i love them but remember it pays to use
them properly
they come in three types flowery waxy
and all rounders
for mash fried or roasting flowery
potatoes like king edwards are brilliant
for boiling or salads use waxy potatoes
like charlotte
[Music]
if you want the best of both worlds in
your kitchen go for an all-rounder like
desiree
i'm using them to make incredible oven
chips next
when i was growing up food in britain
was somewhat different to what it is now
no one had heard of organic you couldn't
even buy avocados in the shops where i
lived paris kitchens might have been
cooking nouvelle cuisine but it
certainly hadn't made any inroads around
our way moulton at lunch when i was
growing up was very plain
pretty trashy but i still love it now
and again fish fingers with a delicious
chip butty
the secret
of a good chip butty
is in the potato
now these are desiree
potatoes one of my first ever jobs
was working in a chip shop i used to put
sacks and sacks of potatoes into the
rumbler which was then the potato peeler
all day long today i'm gonna do
something a bit healthier
for my oven chips with a twist
simply peel
slice and blanch for three to four
minutes
drain season
and cover well with propeca
spread evenly over an oiled baking tray
and place into a preheated oven for 20
minutes
simple as that
next up easy fish fingers
this is pollock
a really nice firm delicious
fish got the fish in finger size batons
of fish
put them onto your plate and just
lightly salt them you can do that
literally 20 minutes 30 minutes before
you start cooking the fish
it firms the fish up beautifully
and it allows it to become a little bit
more durable especially in the pan now
for the coating start by thoroughly
coating the fish in seasoned flour
and then just roll it
to get rid of those little sharp corners
because then
it stops those corners almost burning in
the pan
in to your egg wash
and really coat them
wonderful and then this is dill
goes brilliantly well with a fish
and run the dill through my breadcrumbs
that makes it more aromatic
lay them
onto your breadcrumbs
nothing wrong with the chip butty
nothing wrong with fish fingers
just give it a lovely modern twist
beautiful once the fish fingers are
thoroughly coated they're ready to pan
fry
and they'll need around three minutes on
each side
i want the fish fingers to be nice and
crispy get a really nice color on them
first and then we'll flip them over
and finish them with butter
bring the heat up into the pan
and a nice
little knob of butter
that'll work wonders with the
breadcrumbs and the dill
nice and carefully
take them out
they look and smell incredible
stay nice and crispy
now to assemble my chip buddy starting
with buttered thick crusty bread
[Music]
slice of bread
mop up that amazing flavor
on slice in half never slice in an angle
my mouth is salivating beautiful
on with the ship butti there's one thing
missing
and it signifies that i've never
forgotten the joy i've come for food but
my god that makes me feel like a
nine-year-old
excuse me for a moment we
want to stuff my face
[Applause]
[Music]
homemade fish fingers and my ultimate
chip buddy so simple to make but trust
me it tastes amazing
[Music]
when i was a kid there wasn't a lot of
spare money in our house to spend on
fancy ingredients but mum was brilliant
at what she did let me tell you so we
had really tasty hearty food great cakes
amazing puddings all made with the
freshest ingredients that's right isn't
it yes
let's get this show on their old town
we're cooking the kind of food mum
always dished up starting with a family
favorite steamed egg pudding with a
glorious butterscotch sauce
they weren't cool desserts on those days
were they no it was puddings puddings
now
i'm gonna sieve the flour would you i'll
chop here sean chop those dates please
that was a favorite wasn't it amazing
sew it in
okay but it's almost like an
old-fashioned dessert wasn't this themed
and everything was sort of steam you had
jam really poorly mm-hmm
so the zest the orange makes that really
nice and fragrant sort of helps get that
richness to the suit
okay yeah
brown sugar in
this is such an easy recipe
yes looks fantastic on the table
and then treacle
cheek it in
oh look at that
there's something quite
magical about a spoonful of treacle can
you add them in there please thank you
and crack an egg
lightly whisk it and mix that into the
milk
if i pour in the egg and the milk would
you give that little mix up please yep
thank you
nice
nice and slow
don't go too fast
you see i always just think that it was
an old-fashioned desert steamed
pudding do you ever remember me
tumbling around your knees trying to
sort of get in there yeah so you like to
lick the ball didn't you all the time
yeah
now lightly grease
the mold you're always willing to help
but not with washing up some things
never cheat i think i was allergic to
the soap how was your excuse
kids will enjoy this tonight won't they
delicious paper
that goes on so the secret
behind the parchment paper is to keep
that nice and tight tight yep
there we are
good
yeah oh hey wash my hand
tightly cover with foil and place in a
pan of water and let it steam for around
two hours with a lid on
are you going to wash up gord
just for once wash up mr ram oh dear
goodness
you like that smash
mom you handed it to me and you dropped
it come on whilst mom forces me to break
the habit of a lifetime dude that's the
thought you're washing up it does that
to you
here's how to make an amazing
butterscotch sauce to serve with the
pudding
add butter into a pan
brown sugar
golden syrup
and a pinch of salt
and vanilla seeds
melt and combine over a medium heat
stir in the cream and simmer until
thickened
that's the taste of my childhood inner
jug right there and it will keep in the
fridge for a week
[Music]
now for the main course my all-time
favorite shepherd's pie what's the
secret
behind a really good
shepherd's pie
i would think the vegetables you use and
growing in it
so we're gonna use leeks and onions and
then start browning off the mince you
know no color no flavor i've never
forgotten that you know that yeah
so
good to have color gotta have color
otherwise it puts that grey tinge on the
shepherd's pie that looks sick greasy
and cheap and nasty
they don't want that do we and i know
you don't do cheap or nasty let me clear
your peelings now huh all right thank
you very much there's no nails in there
now is there no
don't be chicken
i remember
your
amazing shepherd's pie
and that lovely little restaurant used
to work in sheep street in stratford
so you never got food sent
back no
sometimes they complained that there was
no
come on no i'm telling you
you never ever got a complaint no
how long do you work at that restaurant
for
six shoes six years
what are you cooking i'm gonna make okay
i sort of modern version of nanny's
shepherd's pie dad shouldn't manny be
doing the cooking because she's the
better cook excuse me right mum would
you would you chop our onion please
darling yeah oh gosh your eyes are gonna
water
daddy what's in this spot sorry
in there we got a delicious steamed
treacle and date pudding let's just
separate it for you
how do skeletons call their friends
how do skeletons call their friend i'm
not too sure on the scalabone on the
skin tilly come on
okay so two cats are in a race one is
called one two three and the other is
called under 12. who won
depends who's the fastest cat one two
three because under 12 cats sank
[Music]
oh goodness
tells why do you make a nice cup of tea
for honey want me to disappear
thank you
bye so give that a little fry off okay
nice
quarter these jokes they get worse
she's certainly having a bit of fun
booster sauce worcester sauce that's
going to give that really nice spicy
seasoning
oh thank you oh that's hot you okay yeah
tomato puree in
you could put a ton of tomatoes in this
if you want you could yeah
put that mince back in there once it's
drained
i'm just going to put a little touch
i know you'll go crazy at this a little
touch of red wine
really
why the red wine well because i'm going
to make it nice and rich
okay
produce the red wine down yeah and then
start covering your mince
with your stock
now i'm gonna bring it up to the bowl
okay and then get some fresh rosemary
okay
like it'll taste yes please
is it hot
it's a little bit hot be careful
well i don't like the way
i'm sorry
oh god
as it cooks out the wine and the alcohol
will disappear it'll be delicious trust
me
now god spring onions we'll chop up
and that's going to go through
the mashed potatoes it's going to sit on
top of that nicer i like that savory
yeah delicious mince it's laced with all
that red wine
nice so sprinkles into there please mum
and i'm going to drain off the potatoes
hi there hello hello
oh hi jack hi hi hello hello jack have a
nice day school yeah
yeah
so we'll dry out those potatoes and then
mash them no oh can i mash them would
you okay um holly slice a little knob of
butter in there for jack please
so what was the restaurant you worked
down there were you a chef
cook
i love the diplomacy were you a chef i
was a cook
exactly that
not really
you used to help me with these little
right your kids do
no potatoes
these are nice and fluffy aren't they
aren't they and do you want them little
delicious mashed potatoes yeah with no
lumps in there
hey weren't you getting it
huh
it's great having you back in the
kitchen mommy now yeah huh seriously
brings back good memories
no
just
why'd you do that dad i just want to
fork it to get it nice and spiky
so i want that nice crispy topping
and then lightly grate that cheddar
cheese on top and that goes in the oven
literally 20 minutes 180 minutes jack
can you open the door please
that looks lovely doesn't it
even though you said you didn't like it
earlier okay
back in the day mama's meals all came
with two veg and this is no different
but with a modern twist
braised peas and carrots with a
fantastic homemade mint butter
shepherd's pie
glazed on top that looks lovely doesn't
it doesn't it
and then the carrots
oh seeded coats that's why i didn't put
carrots in let's put them on the side
i'll see
last job before serving pour that
gorgeous butterscotch sauce over the
pudding
okay i'll take one at a time
that smells incredible
this is my ultimate childhood dinner
shepherd's pie with crispy cheese champ
topping sweet buttery peas and carrots
and a steam date pudding dripping in
butterscotch sauce all that's missing
are the family megan jack tilly holly
hello now take a seat she's like digging
it i'm good cosplay server guys so now
this is your recipe
this is nan's recipe but modernized mum
how is that it's very nice but i can't
taste the wine no that's right i said
give it a chance to cook out nunny wow
that's amazing do you like your tools
yeah man you did a good job excuse me
none of these recipes
revamped oh i have a sneaky feeling that
you might have been sitting down and
letting them do all the work
i think we've got a new set and again no
wonder it's so delicious
on that note cheers to nanny
nanny thank you for coming good to see
you you're brilliant by the way you
still didn't do the washing up there are
loads more great home cooking recipes on
my app cook with me you can find it in
the app store good luck
packed full of sumptuous homely dishes
today's all about comfort food i think
every home cook needs recipes that don't
just taste delicious but satisfy the
soul too the type of food that wraps its
arms around you and gives you big hugs
so when you want to give your family and
friends a big serving of love here's my
ultimate comfort food
dish is guaranteed to make you feel cozy
even on the coldest of days
first up a breakfast that'll bring you a
warm glow in the morning my spiced baked
porridge perfect for a big comfort
family breakfast
for lunch i'm pulling out all the stops
with a fantastic twist on one of
britain's favorite comfort dishes ginger
beer battered fish with chilli minted
mushy peas
if you're gonna do it
do it properly
for dinner my youngest daughter tilly is
in the kitchen and we share the secret
ingredient in every comfort food dish
happy memories
did you like to help nan make your hot
pot when she made them for you
always
such as hot pot with beetroot and potato
gratins on the menu for dessert spiced
apple compote
silly we're on for a treat this is my
ultimate comfort food breakfast
lunch and dinner
first up it's breakfast my spiced baked
porridge
absolutely love it why
i grew up with it there's something very
scottish about porridge it's that kind
of sort of great start to the day
my father used to say
porridge needs salt
and salt only
it separates the men from the boys
didn't really like it it was insistent
salt puts hairs on yours
i used to sneak a couple of sugar lumps
from cafes and put them
in my porridge without him watching
these days my porridge has much more
flavor than just salt it's packed with
fruit nuts and spices add vanilla seeds
to porridge oats or oatmeal
really important just to rub the vanilla
through
the oatmeal makes it
nice and fragrant now
a little teaspoon
of cinnamon makes it spicier and then
nutmeg
[Music]
already
that
smells incredible i quite like making
this up week at a time and
jack absolutely loves it now
whole almonds
now if you don't like that kind of
crunch running through the porridge you
can chop these up or blend them to a
powder but i quite like the sort of
texture hazelnuts incredibly good
a really nice crunch keep your vanilla
pod in there as well that just gives it
even more lift and of course once it's
baked just pull it out instead of sugar
i'm adding sweetness with fruit fresh
pears and raisins
cranberries are great as well chopped
apricots as well dried apricots in there
dried mango i love dried fruit next pour
in a pint of milk and mix
this can be done the night before left
in the fridge
and then
a couple of minutes before you go to
bake it add your cream
now
into your dish
it looks quite liquid
but by the time it bakes
has this really nice rich crust on top
and then
just a nice little nutmeg
on top
now bake at 180 for 30 to 35 minutes
then take the porridge out sprinkle on
demerara sugar and grill to create a
sweet golden crust
and sort of glaze on top
beautiful
literally
for three to four minutes
look at that
that makes me feel proud to be scottish
because it's perfect for a big comfort
family breakfast it's rich it's
sumptuous
and it's just a humble oatmeal
phenomenal especially in the winter my
spice baked porridge with all those nuts
and fruit it's a bowl full of love to
start the day
[Music]
next i'm showing you how to cook the
comfort food i crave
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
make them
[Music]
my ultimate comfort food has to be
sausage i grew up on the classic british
banger made with ground pour salt pepper
spices and bread crumbs and i'm using
these ones for dinner
the general rule with sausage the higher
the meat content the better they'll
taste
[Music]
for my ultimate lunch i'm frying fish so
you'll need an oil you can get to a high
temperature here are the different oils
you can use
groundnut oil it's made from peanuts and
it's used a lot in south east asian
cooking
rapeseed made from those yellow
flowering crops this has the lowest
saturated fat content of any oil and has
a lovely delicate flavor
sunflower oil made from sunflower seeds
is mildly nutty
a good cheap all-rounder with a neutral
flavor is vegetable oil which is the
blend of oils like corn soybean and
sunflower
[Music]
apples were my favorite fruit growing up
originally came from china but today in
britain we grow over 2 000 different
types
[Music]
the most popular eating apples in the uk
are braven and gala but don't miss out
on some of the older types like the
sweet nutty russets and fragrant coxes
when it comes to cooking apples it's got
to be a sharp brambly which i'm using as
part of my compot for lunch
you know that feeling when you really
want a particular dish and nothing else
will do that's comfort food ultimate
comforting lunch has to be fished with
peas i've loved it ever since i was a
kid and to make it even more delicious
i've given it a few modern tweaks
for my ultimate fish i'm doing the best
crunchiest lightest batter imaginable
with a hint of ginger
to go with it chilly minted mushy peas
[Music]
in order to make sure that the batter
stays nice and crispy and the fish stays
nice and firm
the secret is to season the fish salt
and pepper that will draw out the
moisture and that will keep the fish
really nice and firm
put it in the fridge for around 10
minutes to let the seasoning work its
magic now the batter as always
when making any batter always sieve the
flour i want a bit of heat in the batter
so
a nice teaspoon of cayenne pepper
season the flour salt and pepper
and then
two teaspoons of baking powder
this
almost lightens the load with the batter
now ginger beer
it gives that batter the sort of unique
spicy individual flavor it's delicious
with a fish and a nice tablespoon of oil
just basic vegetable oil gives it a nice
sheen
give it a good mix
you really want it almost like the
consistency of
double cream
too thin and the batter runs off
especially when it hits the fryer too
thick and it actually prevents the fish
from getting cooked so you've got to get
it to that just that sort of double
cream texture
let it rest for as long as possible to
give you an even textured batter
now the season should have worked its
magic and drawn out the excess moisture
from the fish so it's on to the next
stage
fish
has gone slightly firmer
perfect for frying
start by coating the fish in flour
seasoned with pepper
pat that nice and dry into your hands so
you haven't got any excess flour the
flour stops the batter from running off
the fish i'm just gonna check to see if
my oil's ready by putting a little touch
of batter
into the fryer
you see it bubbling straight to the very
top
that tells you that the oil is ready
never really ever
fill the pan above halfway
if the oil starts to get too hot
first thing you do turn off the gas
second thing add some oil into it to
cool it down
hold the fish by the corner
unless you put it in
and roll it round
then gently slap the fish on the sides
of the bowl to get rid of excess batter
now
in
and lay away
and just gently drop it in
twist
your pan
that stops it from sticking
at the bottom
oil should be gently sort of bubbling
away
but notice as we're frying the fish
there's no
spitting of any water from the fish
fry the fish for three to five minutes
gently turning halfway through
once the batter is golden and crisp it's
ready
look they look stunning it's like these
big crispy pillows of beautifully
textured cotton leave the fish to rest
on a kitchen towel to blot excess oil
meanwhile it's quick and easy chilli
minted mushy peas
now how much you peas a little teaspoon
of olive oil
and a nice
knob of butter
into the pan
shallot
finely chopped that adds a bit of
sweetness to the peas slots into the pan
chili
these are delicious when you eat peas
and they're slightly spicy
they're even better
garlic
in the peas sweat off the chilli the
garlic and the slots
before the peas join those spices simply
blanch and salted boiling water infuse
with their perfect partner
fresh mint stalks and all
and then put your frozen peas in now
what's the peas i've got nice and soft
drain them now take off the stalks and
then add your peas to the shallots
i love that sound
mix all that chili and garlic
in there
a little seasoning
finishing the frozen peas off like this
absolutely delicious
onto your board
crush
now
you cannot beat
crushed delicious peas look at that
those peas is incredible
top with chopped mint
chilli minted mushy peas so simple and
perfect with easy ginger beer battered
fish a nice spicy crispy batter and that
just
reaffirms
the importance of comfort food if you're
gonna do it
do it properly
[Music]
my spicy twist is proof you can update a
comforting classic
and the best way to eat this is with
crispy buttered sauteed potatoes cooked
with garlic rosemary and thyme
to take this happy food to a whole new
level
[Music]
no question about it the best comfort
food is definitely homemade wonderful
smells filled in the kitchen delicious
freshly cooked food and a big side order
of nostalgia for me fantastic stews hot
pots and puddings will always hit the
mark and remind me of my mum that's why
i love them my ultimate comforting
dinner is a real favorite in our house
and i hope
it will always remind my kids of me
[Music]
and joining me in the kitchen to cook
the comfort food of my childhood is my
youngest daughter tilly
my ultimate comfort food dinner is a
stunning sausage hot pot which will
serve with a gorgeous potato and
beetroot gratin
now i love hot pot you love hot pot
and you love sausages right yeah
what do you enjoy most about sausages
um i just love having them
with the baked beans sometimes with
baked beans sometimes these are
little button mushrooms okay you just
take them into there like that
and keep them whole and cut them into
quarters please
now the important thing about cooking
sausages is they need a bit of color
right no color no flavor exactly get the
pan
nice and hot
how was school today
school was good thanks we got to go out
and make snowmen sausages in
okay butter mushrooms in there please my
daddy
[Music]
see
now
i want you to wash your fingers but you
know how to slice onions right
definitely i'll be good now
sausages
are getting lots of color because this
is going to cook slowly
and it's sort of daddy's version of
the kind of hot pot the other one
nannies to make for me yeah once you've
got the color on them
and take them out
to rest okay
a little normal butter okay into the pan
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize
so that will go down by half
give that a little fry
okay
salt in
i want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that gets them
really nice and dark now get your thyme
in
pick off all the little buds
that will get the onions packed with
flavor mmm that's not nice nice
mushrooms in give them a nice little
stir
did you like to help them make your hot
pot when she made them for you i used to
always help them make the hot pot
always
now my mum would never have used this
but a's balsamic vinegar brings out the
flavor of the onions right now look at
her onions
look beautifully caramelized
the vinegar has given that nice sort of
gloss i'm going to put my sausages back
in here now from there
some red wine
red wine end
got the flavor underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is gonna release all that flavor inside
as well look at the colour of that
does that look pretty nice smell and
it's still not cooked yet up to the ball
really important to boil it here because
it won't ball in the oven 170
in the oven literally
18 to 20 minutes then she goes
nice
to go with my hot pot rich golden creamy
potato gratin it's a true comfort food
classic and i'm adding a delicious twist
beetroot
start by gently heating double cream
[Music]
then peel and thinly slice potatoes and
cook beetroot
next rub garlic around the edge of your
dish to thoroughly season with a
glorious flavor then grease with a good
layer of butter
arrange alternate layers of potato
and beetroot
seasoning in between
end with a neat layer of potatoes
and pour the hot cream over the top
bake in a preheated oven for an hour or
until the potatoes are tender
[Music]
potato and beetroot gratin are bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish
now for the apple compote what we need
to do first is to get these peeled
and sliced
i get my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a little taste of that
is this thanks for the warning
both so well he blew my head off
they're incredibly acidic
okay and you need to cook them those
wonderful red apples you've got are
called brae burns what other apples do
you know green ones what they called um
i'm not too sure what the green one is
another word for your nan
grandmas no
red no pink lady apple no
granny smith granny smith apples that's
right
what we're gonna do
is cook the cooking apples
and
the eating apples together
i love the combination of the tartness
from the brambly cooking apple with the
sweetness of the brae bun get the pan
nice and hot
and sprinkle the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger and three little cinnamon sticks
i want you to remember that because
we're gonna look for them
okay because once we've used them
and they've worked their magic i need to
pull them out see all the sugar
dissolving
definitely now we just let that go a
little bit darker
okay
and then
doesn't it
give that
a nice
little
toss
okay
nice golden color cinnamon in ginger in
so
we're cooking down the apples
butter in
gently cook until the apples soften then
take off the heat
and they go into there what's that
coming out dad so that is a little bit
of the puree i'll show we'll do that in
a minute how many ginger
four four ginger
and three cinnamon three cinnamon out
with the cinnamon
we've got another ginger gingers and
take
a spoon
of apples
smells so nice how nice is that look see
the colory apples
let's put these in the fridge to get
nice and cold
that's the compost sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to crown the top
do you separate the egg whites into
there for daddy
all right egg whites are in they're
great separate
i figured
[Music]
and i'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
you turn up the speed
[Applause]
good girl
[Music]
please now let's see if you've got a
really nice stiff peak so you lift them
up
and that is what i call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad not bad
next in a separate bowl whip double
cream until stiff
nice and slowly
so cream whips so much quicker
yeah
nice
we're gonna
put some delicious lemon zest
which will make the cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover caramely compot puree
you mix that in nice and carefully
so it's like this apple
butterscotch
now to make the cream even lighter fold
in those whisked egg whites and sugar
egg whites
into the cream
just
nicely fold that in so you bring your
glasses back out
manage the glasses yep
good girl
silly we're on for a treat
open up the piping bag
now twist the end
now you could spoon this in but i want
to just give a nice little lift it also
gives it a nice pattern
lemon on top
back in the fridge
the beetroot and potato gratin
that lovely that's lovely
sausages
finished with a flat leaf parsley
wow look at those two beauties
it doesn't get any more comforting than
that does it for one of the best hot
pots
ever tilly that looks amazing
i know well done
this is my ultimate comfort food dinner
sausage hot pot with potato and beetroot
gratin followed by apple compote
food with guaranteed feel good factor
mommy jack holly megan
doesn't it
[Music]
it smells amazing
tasty delicious one of my favorite it's
so tasty i love it it's so good i love
the mushrooms as well that is so nice
and so simple when i was your age guys
nanny was making this for me
in those days the sausages weren't as
fat as those days you would ride to
school on dinosaurs
excuse me i'm not out
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
you